been so bad out here once you get used
to it still a lot we haven't seen them
and alone for us to do yeah
buck up we're just getting started the
best Final Fantasy games are often
regarded for their laird characters and
stories but that will not be Final
Fantasy 15 s legacy save for a few minor
arcs and impressive cutscenes the story
of the deposed Prince Noctis and his
three bodyguards ultimately leaves
little room for its stars to evolve or
earn your affection but finishing Final
Fantasy 15 story prepares you for
difficult trials tucked away in iou's
the game's impressive looking and
bountiful open-world its best quests and
treasures extend well beyond the needs
of noctis's fight and it's these
pursuits that make you appreciate your
brothers and arms and Final Fantasy 15
in the long run we first meet Noctis and
his crew enroute to the princes wedding
a political marriage to his childhood
friend designed to unite their families
opposing nations but shortly afterwards
we learn that noctis's father king regis
was duped by the promise of peace and
violently overthrown in an effort to
reclaim his birthright and restore
balance to his world
noctus must locate ancestral weapons
scattered and lost tombs across EO s--
battle hundreds of monsters and go
toe-to-toe with all-powerful gods this
is the Hokkien seems we woke the big guy
up but this is a fantasy anchored by
more mundane real world concerns
noctus and companies sleep in motels eat
at roadside diners and gossip with
down-to-earth cooks between missions
other stylish elites make an appearance
during cutscenes of course but your
meetings with commoners far outnumber
your royal rendevouz there are at least
80 side quests and only fourteen story
chapters for the vast majority of the
game there's a very real disconnect
between your party in the outside world
that's never properly addressed I was
just thinking I could use a few extra
hands for catching frogs to be precise
wait what Final Fantasy 15 embraces
contemporary open-world principles from
the start outside of a few linear story
missions you're free to explore
sprawling environments and take on
dozens of side quests at your leisure
but dedicating your time to rewarding
pursuits has a side effect the more
comfortable you become living in AOS
doing honest work the further away and
less important noctis's concerns feel it
doesn't help that most NPCs would rather
talk about their magazine publishing
business or recipes than important world
affairs and as far as your bodyguards
are concerned their content cruising
around AOS and their fancy car cracking
jokes and taking selfies with noctis's
crew gladiolus the muscle Ignace the
brains and Prompto the comic relief what
you see is what you get each character
is treated to a time in the spotlight
during story missions but these events
which seem major in the moment have
little long-term impact they make for
upbeat travel companions offering tons
of colourful banter during your travels
but it is disappointing to see
supporting characters a group that
typically has diverse backgrounds and
curious personalities in Final Fantasy
games relegated to cliched unbending
roles
she's a messenger a spirit faithful to
the Oracle Oh for real during the first
half of the story missions are designed
to familiarize you with the ebb and flow
of the open world but more importantly
you learn how to fight there's a lot to
manage despite only having direct
control over noctus which makes for a
satisfying juggling act once you
understand the game's demanding pace in
the extent of your abilities though you
can pause the action to re-equip
characters and use items mid-battle
combat is otherwise a non-stop fluid
process by holding down a button noctus
will deliver a combo attack until he's
interrupted by an enemy if you're quick
you can press another button to phase
through an incoming attack and continue
your assault
noctus can also warp attack from great
distances swap between four weapons made
combo if need be cast magic and our rare
occasions summon godlike Astral's onto
the battlefield to mop up enemies
Astral's are powerful beings that align
with Noctis throughout the story to be
summoned later in a time of need but
each of the four Astral's you acquire
calls for very specific battle and
weather conditions meaning you have very
little control over when they actually
appear where you could always count on
summons to save the day in previous
Final Fantasy games it's disheartening
that they usually fail to appear during
Final Fantasy 15 s most difficult
battles more often than not you can at
least rely on magic to hammer tough
enemies when Astral's seem out of reach
spells can be crafted by bottling ice
fire and lightning harvested from
elemental springs and dungeons in the
overworld and you can also combine these
elements with items for increased
potency and extra status effects it's
important to pay attention what you cast
but also where you cast it as your party
can suffer frostbite burns and shock if
they are standing too close to the point
of impact while this may sound bad it
has an appreciable layer of strategy to
combat that makes you weigh the risks
and benefits of taking the easy way out
as you earn experience and level up your
party earns ability points that can be
spent to upgrade things like AI
behaviors in battle or bolster noctis's
suite of skills you can also unlock
passive abilities that help you earn
money and experience points faster as
you explore the open world but all told
EP is in short supply and the Ascension
grid is fractured into many categories
making it difficult to decide where to
focus your efforts ultimately
accessories do the heavy lifting when it
comes to character customization they
typically increase characters stats but
also offer protection from status
ailments and influence your companions
behaviors most weapons are less exciting
and varied and you may be shocked and
disappointed when you discover that each
merchant only carries one or two for the
entirety of the game and don't be fooled
by the outfits menu no one sells outfits
in the game meaning you're stuck with
your initial set which is 2 per
character or 4 if you count optional
jackets it seems odd that there are so
few options not only because a menu
screen is dedicated to them but because
the few outfits you can wear come with
small but noticeable effects on your
party's attributes presuming you let it
pull you along with minimal side
tracking it's possible to finish Final
Fantasy 15 story in just over 30 hours
this is short by Final Fantasy standards
but after the credits roll the real fun
is just getting started over 60 hours
into my quest
I recently discovered strange locked
doors unlike anything else I've seen up
until this point nested inside the inner
sanctums of already high level dungeons
I have no idea how to open them but my
party's amazement in addition to my own
is enough to make me want to find a way
I'm also in the middle of a quest line
that promises to reward me with the most
powerful weapons in the land but only if
I can take down massive creatures that
rival even the Astral's impressive scale
Final Fantasy 15s in-game content is
some of the best in the entire game and
when it's all said and done these are
the moments I will remember most it's
been a long ten years since Final
Fantasy 15 was first revealed and
tasting games have changed in the
meantime
while it's safe to assume fans and
Outsiders will find some aspect of Final
Fantasy 15 disappointing be at the
shallow story or the outlandish cast it
would be hard for anyone to deny that
Final Fantasy 15 is a fascinating
experience whereas characters fail to
impress Final Fantasy 15 beautiful world
and exciting challenges save the day
[Music]